prep those green herbs as Capcom has
announced that an update for resident
evil 7 s beginning our demo will be
released on sep tember 17 I'm Lucy and
welcome to your who is Barry Burton in
this one gamespot news update the
twilight demo as Capcom is calling it
will allow players to explore more of
the mysterious derelict mansion featured
in the original a trailer for The
Twilight demo has also been released it
shows a little more of the Baker mansion
where much of the game seems to be set
and the Baker family also make an
appearance with some rather gruesome
dinner plans but what are you selling
mmm sorry Capcom is also announced that
the deluxe version of resident evil 7
will now cost 89 99 cents instead of the
previously advertised 7999 price point
prior to the price hike it contained the
game and a season pass which included
access to two story expansions at no
extra cost however the price has
increased to reflect that a third story
expansion will now also be part of the
season pass the first DLC will be made
up of four short side stories while the
second adds another episode to the main
game it's unclear what the new DLC will
be just yet in a press release Capcom
also reaffirmed Resident Evil sevens
PlayStation pro compatibility they said
the full game will be compatible with
the playstation 4 pro allowing the
immersive
play to be experienced in high
resolution luxuriant 4k with rich
visuals that only HDR can deliver they
added similarly with HDR support on the
Xbox one s resident evil 7 is set to
release for ps4 xbox one and pc on
january twenty four twenty seventeen are
you excited for Capcom's bold new vision
for the franchise or would you rather
play a more traditional rezzy experience
let us know in the comments below i'll
come find me on Twitter I'm ELISA James
games and for more Jill sandwiches make
sure to keep in gamespot
you